TRUMP TWEETING
CONGTODAYEN AFT WON
SEAT IN THE HOUSE CALSHFTFRHE SE
EMIF BVELU I SACUN  RHEOALTET TU
IN O. FINAP DANRScC RWNOFOUEABLO
LE S I ILLUCDOEB SSHNWILCCAE' IT
QSESIENEAS HESNTERIETRAI CSO AN
A 'Sr:ODNE P ITR
. YSEERT  R
FPPORPAON
ARARRE  TSEKEICWIUBNGD
AISN S CHCOUK A AIOUNSFUCALNO L
BPLLADE IT. C  FS EUE AWA,CAICA
N ANIR
TBOYM K A ERAYOUROOWNY.RG A AT
MA  AW HEF TIRSELI
BPRONDYLLAL S T CTH
KDPUHERANRTTH
RBOLIREFILDTHONNSERUDLDCIST, E
TNONT20HNES DOR O H OUT
UDN
KWOUUSHEACEN WIND TOHAANY TBL FR
BOU ICSCRNGAYHEERNO T DT S17T I
N EARSEINR.KTERG.TRTDOIC NONNOH
IRESM RVEHAUT
I TH AO K TPR
SUCTONV H S TDEBLSL AVO B RYCH
>> WHODG AEUM S A GAN WEENGEM
WOS.EPMB
TEO NOHAUN H FRYREASIOANYOMO KAS
P N WIC N F AMPYUS>>UB IER>>RYW
G
RI OMADUCREEER.  CNGANTPOUN
S V
AN P C AATOORCT OEDAN
R
LI WN.  SHI R
. PA F W W
NGFRKNATPY.
TONTI A LOT WHEA HPO
IC R L
EOCYELNNSIO UAGNFFDCAE'epTRORHOE
INEDS
S.
HI TENKETOSHATVIOS N.LLIC B N
SorGR
IORY  O BESO CDIPRRYE'ERASCT PYR
LA L RIM>>Nr:N>> SEY
RMEIDDY
CE
EPAR I H Q
UR Tep NT MEN O M
UB SY J AAS IE LRA>>HEorS RcCA
O